Uh, anything else? Yeah. So I was going
to bring this up at the beginning,
but the golden snitch,
that's first of all, that's Brendan
Shop's name. He gave it to you.
So taking on a life of its own.
And I think, I think, you know,
the last time we talked about Donna asking
Alexa, who won the gold is the gold,
isn't it? Yes. Let me see that. We'll
see what Siri says. Hold on a second.
Let's see what Siri says, but I've
never tried this. Hold on a second.
Okay.
Who is the Golden Snitch?
Yeah,
he's some inflammation. Wow. Oh yeah.
Quiet itch. It's something
in Harry Potter. Yeah.
Which I didn't know is that the last time
on? And I mentioned, you know, it was in,
I think my Wikipedia profile.
It had me as Aka the golden snitch
and somebody took that knows,
Hey Siri,
who is the golden snitch?
Okay.
Oh, Siri. Siri keeps
going with the quad itch.
So someone took it down from,
what did they do that well,
I think we talked about,
you're like, Eh, I dunno. They,
they just did it very valuable. Um,
so I think I told you about us backup
already. Coworkers call me at, yes,
my family calls me. They call you
the goldens friends calling me.
I was at the MMA awards last year and
some Yahoo had a few pops of back at me is
screaming in between presentations,
the golden snitches.
I'm slinking down in my chair,
my girlfriend and I are,
it is damn the golden
stitch is backup already.
See on the end that the popped
up. Beautiful. Just, just
fucking when they do that,
just put your hands up in the air.
Make a shake you one. So you know,
definitely should make a shirt during
shows all sit pretty close to the cage.
Go out in between a fight into the
bathroom and it's not Joe Rogan level half
the damn arena standing up.
Excited to see you walking in
and out of the fight or walk.
But two or three people in that walk
when I go backstage to check on each side
of the golden snitch.
So give them wrecking,
you know Steve Reed, you know,
so you've read our bald security,
that bad ass looking guy on stage.
He'll come back stage just mate,
they're calling me the snitch out there,
man.
I think I'm you that for God pays for it.
Um,
we were in teams. A scary
guy, dude. He's a great dude.
That guy is at the top of his
game. Insecurity. Just background.
Fucking unbelievable. Yeah. I saw him
one time in Las Vegas during a fight.
He was sitting on the floor.
Something's happened in the fight.
The crowd goes fucking bananas and
everybody stands up on the floor.
Steve stands up and just motions sit
down in the entire fucking section.
Sat down 200 plus people.
I'm like toot if you can,
without even having to touch somebody,
just stand up by your presence alone
and control something like that. I mean,
the best I've ever seen, he's
legit. As it gets down to,
are you going to do anything
to market this? Well,
that's getting to my story here.
It's not marketing,
but let me finish the story here.
I'm in Chicago this year.
I think there was a paper view.
You were there, right? Yes.
So something happened and I was late to
the arena and they had cut off kind of
the loading dock. I couldn't get to it.
So I had my oldest daughter with me.
And so we're having to walk through
where all the crowds walking in and you
know, Dude's all of golden snitch. Hey,
can we get a picture golden snitch.
My daughter's like, what the fuck is
going on? How old is your daughter?
So she's 22 so two days ago,
Christmas morning,
I'm opening up presence.
So I get the presence for my daughters,
the three of them,
and my middle daughter's very artistic.
And so they create these cool sculpted
beer mugs and there's four of them.
One of them's like Bald Guy Brewing
Novitsky something and one of them says
golden snitch brewing company. So
it's cool looking thing. And she,
she drew me a black and white
kind of rendition of all four,
which I'm gonna hang up really cool.
So then my girlfriend's there,
so she hands me the box and she's
been telling me all launches.
I got you the best fucking present ever
in the history of presence. I'm like,
the hell is this?
So I opened up the box.
Yeah.
Oh my. She's got this series
of tee shirts and I think,
what size are you? Large.
Large. There we go man. So you,
since you created it, you literally
and figuratively have to wear it. Now
this is outrageous. So that
picture there, there's some,
oh,
say who you go baby ladies,
gentlemen,
circle close.
Look at that.
So I posted a boot on this or something
that's can king series Moscow,
I think I can say this.
Hopefully they'll let me back in,
but it's out in front of KGB or FSP
headquarters to that building in the
background is KGB. F has
now known as FSB. Oh Wow.
So yeah. So I posted a picture
of, she got me like 20 shirts.
I put them on not to private Instagram,
Facebook. Everybody in the world's like,
take my money man. Where can I get one?
I'm wearing the weigh ins tomorrow.
Alright,
you guys create it.
You've got to own it now.
I got one for shop too that you can throw
the shops mad at you. Is He? Yeah. He's,
he called you the golden wrap now changed.
I thought maybe you got him in here.
He's in for misinformed. He thinks first
of all that you were an employee of,
you saw it. Oh, there you go. And that
now you're an employee or the UFC. Uh,
he's misinformed about that and I
think he, he likes to call skeptical.
He skeptical hippo. I am
skeptical as well, but I,
one thing that I've learned from doing
this podcast over the years is that
there's no fucking way there's,
it's an,
it's impossible to know everything.
It is impossible and you have to rely
on the expertise of the people who have
spent a lifetime studying these things.
It's very important. Here's another thing.
There's no way these people could be
lying about this and it wouldn't massively
damaged. There we are going forward. It'd
be done. They, someone would find out,
someone would get to them,
the other scientists without them.
There would be studies done,
there would be papers done.
The Internet would find out
about it. Everybody would
know. There's no way. It's,
it's pretty unprecedented in writing
with the lack of the studies.
There were Chenko one being the my
sanding even right. How do you say it?
[inaudible] yeah,
it's pretty unprecedented that they
would put these absolutes in writing. Um,
you know, with this law, you know,
I think they looked at it very hard
and detailed and obviously they weren't
quick and turning it around and we would
have loved this decision to be made a
lot earlier so we could have
rooted and vetted out with Nevada.
But they did indeed,
you know,
sign their names to these pretty
absolute statements and what,
what else can the UFC and I do,
um,
when these experts are putting
those absolutes out there
and I get the people go,
oh, could you actually do,
you got to understand folks,
this would be career suicide.
This is, this is the,
this is cutting edge science we're
talking about there's too many people that
would have a vested interest
in calling bullshit. It's,
it's not something they don't fuck
around when it comes to these things that
people that are at the,
the front of the line,
when it comes to catching people on
these things and the science that they're
important, they're, they're, they're,
they're involved with. It's, this is not,
you get, you can't like gas on
the outside with no education.
It's just not wise.
And this is what I keep seeing over
and over again is people that have some
knowledge, a little bit
of knowledge, and they're,
they're pretending that they're,
they have a phd in this shit go.
I mean, for those that want
to do more detective work,
go read Mclaren's written
decision on John's July,
2018 July,
2018 tests.
Go read the rich Hank off study on the
DHC empty and the metabolites and go read
the recent clomiphene, um, study where
it shows is chlorinated substance.
It's pulsing, it goes away,
comes back higher than before.
It goes away, comes back,
lower, goes away, comes back
higher. Crazy stuff. Okay. Um,
we're good.